ethan i didn't get your pizza i'm sorry
i beat that one
chill yeah beef by the way i think we're
live so people can hear us so before you
guys get too in depth about the pizza
i don't know what they're talking about
i don't know what this pizza is
i don't know anything all i know is that
i'm here
to play among us and i'm here to have a
good time
i'm talking right now and this is me
talking and that's really i've had your
phone
right that's fine i just want to hear
you all right good i usually record
everything really low my god
i don't know when they're gonna sort all
that out no one's explained the game to
me yet and i don't think anyone will
[Laughter]
the thing about these types of games is
uh i play them differently
i play them a little different so if
you're expecting some high tier
uh impostering or whatever it would be
for me
just you wait yes you wait man all right
we should at least tell the uh the
muting rules to uh to markiplier
yeah what'd you call me that is his full
name yeah so we're gonna we're gonna
fully deafen up while we're actually
doing our tasks and then when you die
you can fully unmute your mic
and you can talk to other dead people
and then when the discussion happens you
can mute your mic
but you're allowed to talk in the
discussion if you are alive so
as soon as the game go i hit deafen
yeah yeah and then if i'm dead i go mute
during the meeting
yeah yeah during the meeting that's when
the alive people are trying to figure
out i gotta write these down
if you talk
right what's wrong with writing
something down mark is both one of the
smartest and one of the dumbest people
that i know
i have a system so meeting equals talk
indent
if dead if colon dead equals no talk
slash listen can someone
okay all right apparently i'm an
imposter this is great
i don't know what do we do where's the
wiring
i don't know electrical that's probably
where it is that's probably where the
the thing is electrical is it electrical
okay there i am
i need to get to electrical okay i can't
get through this
isn't this a door is this a door it's a
door right
it's a door gas can door it opened okay
got that i solved that puzzle somehow
okay there's wiring in here there's
wiring
there's wiring how do you fix the wiring
okay how do you fix the wiring
where is the wiring it would be in
electrical right
okay i don't know where that is okay i'm
gonna go the med bay where's the med bay
med bay med bay no other way
sorry med bay med bay
oh hello
it's been like three minutes there was
no i didn't find any murders i thought
maybe we should discuss
meeting equals talk i'm talking yes
we also only have a limited time so
don't yeah don't make this the
markiplier
what do you mean i just asked if i was
able to talk
it's i'm not making it about me i'm
sorry that my natural charisma
just impacts everyone so strongly this
is not the markiplier
chilled why didn't he didn't find the
body i refused to partake i refuse to
partake in this hour
hey everyone that doesn't know anything
if you could uh step aside the podium's
uh meant for me right now you saw got to
his body and was trying to click the
word report
whenever this meeting was called he's
over by the top left reactor
i don't know who i just passed somebody
i don't know who i passed because i was
only half paying attention in all
honesty
uh but i just got to his body on the top
left was getting ready to hit report and
then we
got called in so i can say that me and
chilled are safe because we both did
tasks in front of each other questions
are visual asteroids
they are not they're not
what does visual tasks mean you can't
see people doing some of the tasks you
normally can you can't tell if they're
doing them or not
right yeah visual tasks equal off all
right
bye i need to fix
wiring okay all right admin
swipe card swipe card
okay whoa okay let me get the map here
something about the oxygen okay this is
fine
this is all good what does that do what
does that do
what does any of this do oh
that looks cool what is happening
this is neato burrito
oh somebody has been killed uh it was
in the electrical room and i will say
i passed both uh sean and bob
running running away yeah
i didn't go into electrical i ran away
from bob when he was refueling because i
was scared of him
did you kill him in there bub yeah bob
oh was he dead and electrical did i walk
past a body he was dead in electrical at
the at the top side
so i didn't see that so two people who
were up there did not see a dead body is
that what i'm hearing
no we were in the hallway at the bottom
i wasn't in there oh you're in the hole
you were in there
what were you doing they were both in
the hallway as i was running past
and i was going up to a task and i found
the body in the electrical
so i'm just my fight or flight sense did
kick in when bob was chasing me and if i
was about to start
taking up my mace and blowing my whistle
i said typho's been just kind of
vibing by me the entire session too and
it makes me uncomfortable but i
have a question and a statement that i
think is going to help
everybody here okay question number one
where's the med bay question statement
left of cafeteria
top left yeah yeah okay i was in the top
i didn't
you're lying to me no mark you you
almost walked in
you almost walked in you're lying to me
and we're going to
remind you about places no i was in the
top left i didn't see a med bathroom
because he's been standing around
okay i'm trying to compress the med bay
press tab to bring up your map you can
also change it to mouse and keyboard in
the options
we're all gonna die my strategy here is
to let bob do the heavy lifting
and if i can take some uh take some work
off of his shoulders
and that'd be great
oh what the hell what
what is this whoa
well that probably wasn't good let me at
least kill
ah damn it nah damn it i got got you all
sorry i trust what's going on
what's going on i'm pretty sure i just
saw mark vent in front of me
next to navigation what can you go in
the vent
i saw that little leg tuck animation
right at the end of it when he bounced
out of it and then i ran straight to the
book
are we voting for mark right no don't
vote me i haven't even
said my piece okay defend yourself
defend venting i don't know how to do it
[Laughter]
okay if i'm wrong you can vote me out i
feel very happy about that
dude look here's the thing no here's the
thing
here's the thing here's the thing i was
i wasn't just playing dumb i was
actually dumb i didn't know what that
did
that's so unfortunate all right
hey mark welcome to the dead uh
literally i had no idea what that did i
clicked it because it was red
or my button came up and i was like what
the [ __ ] is this and then i popped out
and then someone walked by i'm like well
all right i guess i'm god yeah i was
gonna try to explain there's a little
bit there's like some more intricacies
whenever you're not the imposter we have
a bunch of tasks
to run around and do and obviously you
guys can click sabotage and sabotage
various systems but when you're killer
yeah you can vent out
and you can teleport to some other
events that are close by there's also a
security room that sean
and someone are currently in um so if
you see
different cameras floating around with
like a red blinking light it means
someone's on security and they're
watching that area so they can actually
witness you commit murder so you got to
be careful with that
oh okay visual tasks are turned off
because it makes it too easy for crew
basically in the med bay there's um
like a big green platform and typically
you can see people jump on that and
it'll show this big green like circle go
around them as they get scanned
and if everyone goes in there like five
people can see that everyone's innocent
at the start oh
i'll explain them more later well uh
just found one
dead body no actually it's jack's dead
body jack i found it too i was right
i got so confused for a second i was
like wait i died
unless he's an excellent liar he did
simon says for an embarrassingly long
time
where were you in this whole charade i
was actually in the reactor of typhro
and
was it ryan or bob was saying you guys
and so i ran downwards and i saw bob and
i just said like you know what i'm just
going to stick to bob the rest of the
time since all my tasks are done and
then that's when the alarm
sound basically we could just finish our
tasks honestly
okay what do i do
right now you have you get a list of
fake tasks to do
the bottom right you're doing things
yeah but the thing is the thing pops up
and
uh i don't know what right so when
you're looking at sabotage there's
different systems that are like
highlighted there's like a
there's a lightning bolt that'll cut the
lights so that way people are traveling
in a group someone may be able to sneak
in and get a kill even if they're
grouped up
you can cut oxygen which if people don't
actually fix oxygen in time
uh they'll actually die i won a game
because someone was afraid of me and
they refused to come close to the oxygen
meter
and i just stood there on it until the
oxygen ran out god damn it
okay uh somebody killed him in the
hallway
well ryan and i were together the whole
you're right
it's either z or eve okay so
it's gotta be z or eve so what are your
defenses yeah so i was running around
with chilled
because uh because i had thought that he
was
innocent and so i was like okay i want
to be with somebody i don't want to be
completely alone
the only time that i split off from
chilled was to go and fix
the uh the lighting that was at the very
end so he got killed when i
went to fix the lighting well hopefully
he ran
past the opposite direction away from
lights hold on let me talk let me talk
all right around i went south
and then i went to go fill up the gas
tank and then i met up with everyone in
the lower engine room then the lights
went out
and now chilled is dead i still think
we're safe not voting anyone off right
now honestly we are so close to
finishing our tasks i mean who has
tasked left because i've waited who just
[Laughter]
it was clear it was clear to me what was
happening nobody cared
he could have so easily turned that on
tyler as well because tyler accused you
and now you're dead
exactly i'm surprised oh man the minute
someone says let's finish our test
i automatically vote them like are you
sick of a [ __ ]
ethan call that immediately wade likes
to hold everyone hostage with the tasks
i'm
in space what does the door symbol look
like cause i don't think i've ever just
an
x on all the doors oh wait so here's
here's the question as an imposter can
you not go through doors
i'm suspicious of bob bob why did you
vote for me last round
i was the only one with a solid alibi
all right i'm 100
sure it's ethan because the rest of us
were all together and ethan refused to
acknowledge that i tried to completely
exonerate tyler
i spent like 30 seconds talking about
how tyler could not be it because he was
being really bad at a minigame and
standing still for an extended period
ethan didn't acknowledge that and has
blamed z and tyler in the last round
off of nothing other than them talking
about what they saw and what happened i
think ethan is throwing way too much
blame
to be an innocent what i think the rest
of us believe that the other ones are
safe
i was in my job the entire time so i can
vouch for bob 100
i was with all of you guys i'm
interlocking ethan i think we got him
there
yeah same okay i'm voting bob
[Music]
no you're not oh wait that is me why am
i blue
never blue we get it right did we get it
right oh no
it's z right we're dead oh god no
oh you've smoothed brainstorms [ __ ]
man please wait please do it wait bob is
so
convincing all the time i forgot i'd
like to also
point out i thought bob was the other
imposter because
he decided to not tell everyone he was
right next to me about like 10 seconds
before i was murdered
i thought bob was the other imposter and
i'm an empire he was an imposter
there it is i win
yay i'm a winner my first game
for sure
look i had to teach mark how to play
lettuce
lettuce oh yeah you taught me to play
real
good how to play this game
no i was using sarcas he didn't teach me
to play
when i saw the child was my partner i
had an audible gasp
someone hit play again if you haven't
already hit play again oh that's me i
didn't know you had to play it
how would i know that play again oh you
guys
does anyone want to give me more notes
for this round i got more paper
in front of people okay i didn't know
that venting was a thing so
if imposter if imp
uh vent yes conditional
alone second
question surprise second baby needs your
question answered
can imposters open doors cause i
couldn't figure that out yeah so as an
imposter you can
you can sabotage no no no listen to baby
when i was in the cafeteria's imposter
the doors closed and i couldn't
figure out how to open it and also i
couldn't figure out how to do
literally anything how do you play this
game
you just kill you just kill you you just
kill kill and pretend
you get fake tasks on the left that you
pretend to do so you have an alibi
how do you pretend to do them you
when we were talking about visual tasks
before if you have visual tasks turned
on
some of the tasks you can actually see
people do so then it's harder to fake it
but yeah
dude if i get impossible i'm not going
to kill a soul because i i don't know
hang on it's a lot easier to be a good
guy trust me i don't know
tried to kill me i didn't the baby
listen to me
stop going for her teacher i'm i'm
trying to write it down
mark you have to set the mouse and
keyboard
so considering i've never seen
the crewmate task thing
i wouldn't know where that usually would
be
right hit tab no not just in the room
where it would be in the room well if
it's if he's an impostor he wouldn't
know where to fake it
exactly exactly that's my point that's
what i've been trying to get at so
that's why
it's better if he's a crewman first that
way he can at least
determine that he plays your videos
aren't uh
so i don't watch him watch me watch a
professional's youtube videos on this my
twitch vod
don't watch wade he never does [ __ ]
tasks i i wrote down as much as i could
which was
vent yes if alone and i'm going to
give my videos martin yeah no and that's
only if you're
i'm not listening to him fix wiring
in the storage that's good i know where
the storage is
i know where the storage is do i know
where the storage is
storage storage um meltdown
meltdown meltdown
i made the reactor go nominal
wiring in the storage there's wiring and
wiring
wiring okay
bam wiring done
oh that body in the upper right of
electrical
wait right over electrical it was it was
it the right side of electrical like
deep in the back oh it was in electrical
yeah okay not not in the storage unit i
didn't see anyone coming uh walking away
i did see
the doors were closed when i was trying
to get in there so this person's a
professional
markiplier's done a lot of doors
no i didn't learn the doors no one
answered the door question
i think markiplier's full of [ __ ] about
the doors he was closing doors that i
wasn't closing last round
he knows how to do it that's impossible
and i have proof
well even babies can put shapes in holes
i'm suspicious of tyler because i saw
him run around like a chicken you were
running around
and i was in security when the deaths
happened and i was locked in there
because bob was outside because
before tyler makes me uncomfortable
and then he turned when mark was like
running i think he tried to get an easy
kill
beautiful proof kill
together
no one listens to me i'm practically a
genius
maybe i should just familiarize myself
with the ship maybe i should just do
that
okay there's the engine that's good
there's security
that's probably where the cameras are
lights
lights would be an electrical right
okay that's been fixed uh weapons
weapons web pins oh the doors are locked
again
what is this interesting
oh i was nowhere near admin i was on the
right side ryan saw me go that way and i
downloaded it
i was i was with bob and tesh we were
both locked into storage
i don't think i was terrified of you
guys when we were locked in the room oh
my god
wait where was the body uh where was the
body was that it was it was an admin it
was like around where the uploader
download thing
was like right at the front of it i
don't mean to be a paranoid peter
but here we go see you found both dead
bodies children
you are now i'm now the third person you
have tried to blame this round so far
i was trying to say last time i had
in this beautiful room you saw
jacksepticeye now you're trying to
pin it on me why
yeah it's called organization we got 33
seconds
okay hurry up whoever was the person
that accused me
last time is an imposter so i don't i've
got this
feeling in my stomach about chilled
because he has tried you were the one
that accused markiplier
last time when you said markiplier knows
how to do the doors seconds hurry up and
vote
we'll just skip and if c dies we'll know
it's chilled that's the risk i'm willing
to take
yeah that's really bad
that's real size yeah gonna get you to
see
gonna get you i think i think it's tyler
and chilled i'm almost 100 positive
either that or
bob i don't trust anybody admin where's
my tasks there's my
no not not admin i need navigation i
need to
fix wire again stabilize the steering
in admin admin oh
admin no that's map this is what i need
this is great i'm great i'm the best
i'm a genius did i do it
i thought that way i did it oh ryan's
dead body was at the push button
for the reactor i walked in and chilled
was there that's all i got
i'm the one who reported his body he can
self-report
okay so i'm gonna let the reactor not go
off not get the win and report the body
okay okay that's fine does the reactor
kill everybody yes yes
a report will make it so that you go to
the discussion and the reactor turns off
again
okay reactor kill colon
got it okay this is good evidence
whoever killed him
left it so the reactors are going to go
off and probably vented out of there
because he was up for the top one
how do you know this plan is so good
i don't think it's test or bob i don't
yeah i don't think it could have been
for sure was anybody with ryan pryor i
was off in the security room i was doing
electrical to the left
i saw ryan down and storage doing wires
i
have a plan i'm going to stick by tyler
if i die it's him i'm going for him
there he is yeah i got him
okay yeah let's let's talk let's talk
yeah i'm watching you mom watching you
i'm watching oh no i dropped my pen oh
god oh it's so exposed my entire
backside is exposed
oh no oh god my my notebook my bullet
journal
it's it's all over the floor oh what am
i gonna
do my bullet journal oh god i can't
possibly get it who could ever get it
oh man oh no i'm dropping
my water bottle spilled all over the
floor
oh no i'm so vulnerable i didn't bring
my
uh bulletproof underwear today oh no
oh
wow that's a problem all right guys it
wasn't tyler
come up and do the wiggle just to take
it
i cleared his conscience okay
i'm an imposter that's good
okay so oxygen kills everybody and
reactor kills everybody okay where's
tyler i'm gonna watch him
where is he tyler tyler
where is he where is he tyler
tyler there he is
okay i'm watching you i'm watching you
i'm watching you oh no
my pen is on the floor [ __ ] people
right next to this dead body and they
didn't report it and it was ryan and
and somebody else yeah i actually wanna
i can fifty percent
cleared shields i can i i only got to
him towards the end of that round
but i stuck by him i was totally exposed
and he didn't kill me but i wasn't there
very long
so it's probably not
where did you say you found the body i
found it in an admin but i'm literally
there i literally just
walked in and there was nobody there i
also i literally hit report
i was right next to ryan and i reported
it right in admin i hate to call my
friends liars but who's lying to me
watch tyler and troll because i don't
know which one's lying it's not
i'll stick by tyler again i'll do it
again
i'll follow you i'll follow you i'm
gonna follow you all right please do
i will i'm going to stand that ass i
will
i know i'm the imposter doing this for
alibis sake
oh we're so vulnerable hmm what could we
do
i'm thinking that if i i do this it's
gonna cast enough doubt on myself that
it'll uh clear me for the rest of the
game i'm just gonna
play my ignorance here oh no drop my
pencil oh no i'm so vulnerable in this
quarter
oh no
it's not tyler i can confirm
i was there marco wasn't with me because
i was within the
whole thing you just left admin uh who
was with me when i found the body
that was me reportedly killed me
oh okay i trust test i was alone with
tesh in the admin
for a long time sean was staring at me
doing the upload and it was terrifying
right before you found them
i can clear tesh for sure i went over
fixed the oxygen as i was about to do
the
trash you were with me when you were
waiting right
uh sean wade was the last wait which
oxygen
the the one by the cockpit tyler lied
twice now about where he was and what he
was doing and where no
i literally saw him the whole time i was
with him
but you just said you saw me at oxygen
doing it with you i walked up you were
following me along with mark at one
point so i assumed you still
followed me up by the cockpit but
apparently you turned off and went to
admin and did that one while i did the
one tyler are you breaking my heart
tyler no i i i
did the one bob came up and saw me do
that yeah well i saw him do the top
right oxygen
if it is tyler he didn't kill this one
are we liars
i'm voting i'm voting tyler well i can't
i cleared his name
or maybe actually i don't know yep yeah
sorry tyler i'm sorry i think
i don't remember this okay we gotta be
really careful okay i'm gonna try to get
it
i might try to get a kill here
how do i kill
what happened okay we need to figure
this out because the kill isn't all they
need is a double kill
and we lose uh-oh i just turned the
power back on
i can confirm i just saw you leave out
of there i love there's no dead bodies
in there but i just saw you leave there
okay
yeah jack i only have one question i'm
not i'm not pointing fingers
i kind of ran from that area and i
didn't see you you were bottom storage
bottom right storage doing trash and
then i walked left and i'm up by reactor
now okay did you see wade go into the
lights because i saw him leave there i'm
assuming you turn the lights on because
the lights came back on
i didn't see a single person i was
already past electric you're about to
buy a reactor like in the reactor room
look you guys can vote me all you want
because i can agree that it sounds
suspicious but
well let's see look we can't we're all
impossible we can't get the wrong guy
here so i'm not
saying i was on camera the whole time
and you definitely did not walk into the
reactor room is the only thing that's
confusing and say i walked into reactor
i said i'm up by that area
oh well just because i asked if you were
in the room or not that's important
information what did you see on the
cameras
because i saw that yeah i saw it and
mostly people i saw you walk by
in the area that you said chilled i saw
cash wander by
out of the med bay i think it was i
didn't see anything suspicious i
basically saw a couple people wander by
before the meeting happened i guess i
saw tashko start the meeting
so i don't want to i have no idea who to
vote for i'm willing to take a risk on
on somebody
i i i've already sean i'm literally
voting the first person on the list
thank god i hope jack i'm sorry sure it
is
okay we may have just lost it boys i
really have just
[ __ ] yourselves thanks boys oh no to
be fair i got tyler kicked out so
i'll take the loss oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
what do i do i don't know what i do
i'm 100 not sure what i do do i go kill
someone
is that what i do
the whole time so you could do all the
work and you did it
i didn't do a goddamn thing the whole
time
in that final round i'm like shields
pointed a lot of fingers but none of
them pointed at him and then i thought
no him two times in a row here
again in the reactor room
i mean i clipped you down like we have
to stop meeting in this reactor
[Music]
bye